really think we need to do is make FGM
much more explicit the data the paucity
of the data is shocking there is a lot
that's out there but how can we
ascertain the global scale of this issue
if we don't actually know what we're
dealing with the three million figure
we're all quoting is in Africa alone it
doesn't tackle Indonesia Yemen you a it
doesn't tackle Europe where we know
500,000 women are living with FGM so we
don't understand the scale we don't
understand what needs to be done on a
country-by-country basis to tackle the
problem a solution in Indonesia is
completely different to what we need in
cameroon in Sierra Leone as ana said as
in Senegal we need to be very very
cognizant of what is the global action
plan without that we can't cost a
solution if this is a matter of
resources than great let's just get on
and fundraise but until we are much more
aware about the global scale of this
problem and what needs to be done about
it we can't reach that target of 2015 I
think very kind offer from an NGO
already working in this field thank you
I'll be in touch and but equally all the
NGOs working in this area please get FGM
on your agenda do something more about
it and I've run out of steam go to my
website there are five easy things that
you can do there they may seem little
things and but lastly do what you can
this is going out to the YouTube
community there'll be people watching
all over the world I chose to enter a
competition on Davos you may want to
find out what is happening in your local
community you may wish to fundraise you
may wish to push your government on
various things or your MP know what your
action is and what your agency is and
please just do something its
international FGM day sorry
international anti FGM day on the sixth
of februari that's a week today contact
a journalist talk about FGM
thank you don't feel free to contact me
don't feel you have to contact this
journalism particular I'm already on
board an well I certainly I would agree
with all that's been said um but I think
its first of all so important to
recognize that this is first and
foremost of violation of the rights of
the girl child think about the fact that
most of the people the children who are
subjected to this are between about the
ages of four and maybe 12 I mean this is
a human being that really doesn't have
the right to say no it's imposed on her
the second thing I would say is that
everyone should look at those
organizations that are working in this
arena it isn't a popular cause these
organizations can't generate lots of
resources for their work and so support
those organizations that are truly
making a difference in this area um let
me just also say finally that you know
this is andy just part of a broader
puzzle and and that quite aside from the
simple moral issue it's an eminently
practical issue we're not going to make
progress against global poverty against
insecurity unless girls are brought into
the picture brought into the formal
economy educated and so on this is one
facet of that larger picture and then we
really hope that you whether you're here
right here or watching on youtube will
get engaged and I think Julia really
deserves our thanks and appreciation for
bringing this issue to Davos and to
YouTube to the Davos debate and please
join me in thanking her and all the
panelists here today